So we can get part of the idea really
simply by just replacing this equation
with something that says for
all state and
action, the value of the state is bigger
than or equal to this expression.
This is essentially the q value, for
each assay this is the q value assay.
So that's good and
know we have to add that min thing.
So what do we minimize here?
>> V.
>> So we can't just minimize V like
that, because that's a vector.
>> Right.
>> And
we can't just minimize V sub s
because s is unbound here [LAUGH].
Right, it's like which s
do we want to minimize?
So we kind of want to
minimize all of them somehow.
So the way we're going to write that,
if this turns out to work.
Is minimize the sum.
So that's going to put pressure on all
the individual Vs to be as small as they
can be, so
that it actually equals the maxes,
it isn't just an upper bound on the max.
>> Right,
because if any one of them isn't,
then you don't have the minimum sum.
>> Right, then you can always
move it down a little bit.
>> Right.
>> So this actually is a linear program,
that is the solution to which is
equivalent to the solution to the MDP.
So we can just write down this linear
program and give it to a linear program
solver that runs in polynomial time,
and boom, we get our values V sub s.
How do we get our policy from that?
>> We just choose the action that always
in expectation gives you the best value,
just sort of one [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, we choose the greedy policy
with respect to that optimal value
function.
So this is cool.
This is sometimes called the Primal.
I guess because it
lives out in the woods.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Representation of the linear
program for solving MDPs.
And this is a perfectly
reasonable [LAUGH],
this is actually very useful
from a theoretical perspective.
I haven't seen too many people really
use Linear Programming to solve MDPs.
It's got some overhead associated
with it that seems to make it
a little bit difficult to get it to run
competitively with the other algorithms.
But it's okay, especially if you have a
really good Linear Programming package.
And if you happen to have other kinds
of linear constraints that you need to
throw in,
this is a very convenient way of solving
slightly more difficult problems, MDPs
plus a little bit of extra constraint.
So, does that make sense?
Are you good with that?
>> Yeah I'm good with that.
>> All right, I want to say one
more thing about Linear Programming
by switching away from the Primal
to what's called the dual.
So, Linear Programming has this nice
property that you can actually [LAUGH].
Any linear program, you can change
the constraints into variables and
the variables into constraints,
and you get a new linear program
that's equivalent to the old one.
So this is just true in general for
Linear Programming.
It's linear programming duality.
And sometimes it's a really useful
way of actually solving them and
for putting bounds and
constraints on the solutions.
But in the context of MDPs it actually
does something kind of cool, so
I want to show you that.
>> Okay.
Is it going to be as cool as what
happened when we did support
factor machines?
>> I don't remember that.
>> We did the same thing.
We wrote down a series of equations and
we solved for the dual.
>> Nice!
So, yes, it'll be the same
amount of cool as that.
>> Excellent, excellent.
I look forward to it.